you do so much content that you've
bought yourself the Goodwill to promote
whenever you want you know I think once
you get fake tits that's gonna be a fun
promotion
are you getting fake tits yeah that's
great it doesn't look good on you yeah
it's uh I mean who wouldn't want to go
see him on tour taking a photo with his
titties how long will they be I'm only
planning on keeping them in for three
months and now in you're gonna actually
get them in I'm gonna okay I'm gonna get
it what other kind of affected they're
talking about I thought you were talking
about like a prosthetic ocean I'm
[ __ ] getting breast augmentation
surgery pal what gave you this idea and
and I'm and I'm told that that I can do
D or double D so you know I only heard
Double D no yeah wait what made you do
this
um it's the next logical step for me and
the the the gun that's where that that's
where the bar is at bro that's where the
bar they're gone too far yeah I was
going to sleep last night 8 30 pm and I
was thinking about Tim I was like dude I
could get Tim Kennedy to
hook up the sniper
sniper sniper's tits off
you you could have them on your mom's
house when he's got the titties I would
love that are you gonna change your
pronouns no no no no no as a
heterosexual guy okay cisgender male
white male yeah this is it's um
heterosexual guys
that's what I'm told man I got uh I'm
developing man boobs dude I can fit them
holy [ __ ] dude yeah that's why and when
you know when you're doing it
um whenever my next special comes out
and then and then you'll have the
obviously the removal done at the after
the yeah it's from my next tour is the
gone too far tour
that's where Pierce is going to come
into play I think this is going to do so
well you're going to be on nothing but
PJs
that's kind of what I'm thinking I got I
got the connect for you by the way when
you wanna pull the trigger when you get
your titties he's got to connect
yeah holy [ __ ] dude yeah it's it's good
stuff man it's called Stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole and if you go on
Amazon and type in Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and Order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're at ranked number
30 on all of Amazon and if you buy a
bottle we might go up the ladder and
that would mean a lot so please get on
Amazon and buy Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole yeah